Very good.
Continuing
in
the book of of purification.
The next sub chapter we are
to speak about is
titled do not shape.
So, we're going to be speaking about the
prohibition
of plucking
white or gray hair.
And furthermore, the
encouragement of the prophet
sallall.aii
am to
instead of plucking the gray hair rather
to use dye or use to change the color
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
his father who narrated from his
grandfather that the messenger of Allah
wasallam said do not do not pluck your
gray hairs.
There is no Muslim that will grow a gray
or white hair in Islam except that that
white hair will act as a source of light
on the day of judgment. Why? Well,
because this is very similar to the
stripes that a veteran has. And a person
is Muslim and they endure and they hold
on to Islam
and they remain steadfast on the
path of Allah until they start to
grow old
because traditionally gray hair, white
hair is is a
you know is a hallmark of of age,
right?
then this is a testament to this
person's
to this person's steadfastness on
Islam. And so it becomes a source of
light for them on the day of judgment.
So if we're not to pluck these gray
hairs,
then what are we to do? The author says,
for.
[Silence]
So in the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam they had different
ways of dying or changing the hair
color. They had what is called that
which is is well known. We call it in
English ha and al ketam. Al ketam is
actually a type of plant that when mixed
with a type of tree known as elesma.
They used to mix these two together and
it would form a dye. And this dye is a
little bit deeper and darker than a hat.
And it is likewise very
it will leave a kind of stain
on the skin similar to alah right. It
will wash off after enough time but it
was used in his time saiam
on hair and it was used also on hands
and you know women would use it as well
for beautifification.
The author then says
and anything of the sort. So
is it a condition that a person use
specifically
or that a person use specifically ketam?
No, not necessarily.
However, the only thing that is
prohibited is black.
Black dye. Dying the hair black is
not just disliked. It is it is haram in
the correct opinion.
[Silence]
In the fourth Abu D narrates that the
messenger of Allah
wasallam said and encouraged and advised
that the best thing that you would
change your white hairs with or dye your
white hairs with is
which we described.
for
[Silence]
a shape.
Well,
[Silence]
he says and the the question then
arises is that how do we harmonize
between the narration that we heard just
a few minutes ago and this narration. If
white hair will that a person grows or
develops in Islam will act as a source
of light on the day of judgment. Then
why would the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam advised that it be changed that
it be dyed that it be colored
and the answer to this is in a narration
in Bkari Muslim on the authority of in
which the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasallam says that the Jews and the
Christians do not dye their hair and dye
their white hair or their gray hair. So
so you know
meaning
so you know contradict them right
contradict them. Now what does this
mean? The Jews and the Christians. This
these are huge communities. Does this
mean that not a single Jew everywhere
anywhere
in any time or a single Christian
anywhere or any time will
you know use dye in in his or her
hair? No, that's not what's intended.
What's intended is they do not do it out
of religiosity.
They do not religiously
dye their white hairs. So the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam tells us to
differentiate ourselves from the Jews
and the Christians in our religious
practices. And this is very important.
This is a general
this is a general principle in Islam
and that is
that the legislation of Islam goes out
of its way
to differentiate the Muslim in generally
and specific acts of worship
from the Jews or the Christians or any
other religious group for that matter.
It is a part of Islam and its practice
that a person deliberately
differentiate himself
from all other groups.
Now why is that? This is such a
principle that
Islam
he wrote an entire book explaining this
principle
and he named the book.
He said part of the straight path of
Allah
is differentiating oneself from the
people of hell.
To the point that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
chose
to modify the days that we fast to
modify the way that we fast to modify
the way that we speak to modify the way
that we walk to modify the clothes that
we wear.
For instance,
the
fasting of the day of Ashua Ashua,
right? the the 10th day of Muhaw. This
is a practice that is done by Jews
for instance in Judaism.
So this is a good thing. This is
correct. Not everything they do is
wrong, right? There's some correct
things that they do. And so we don't
just do things that are correct. If it
is correct, we don't throw it out.
But Islam modifies it. So how is it
modified?
We fast ash but we fast another day with
it. So we fast two days. Why? To
differentiate ourselves from the Jews.
Not only that but the fasting itself is
modified
because the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that the Jews fast
on into on in past sunset.
They p they fast past sunset until the
stars
you know become obvious and numerous
in the sky, right? Not just the bright
ones are visible. So the night sky and
the stars are very visible.
So what are we to do when we fast?
As soon as the disc of the sun is no
longer visible behind the horizon, we
break our fast,
right?
and so forth.
And we could we could take many examples
of this even to the point that when the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam came to
Medina he used to keep his hair to the
right or comb it to the side. But it
wasn't short this where you'd
comb it to the side. He would split it
at the side here. comb it over and then
there would be braids and it would
remain in braids and he wouldn't have
his head exposed after that. He'd always
have something on his head. So the only
thing you would see is the braids, three
and sometimes he would have four braids
and that was the way that you know men
kept their hair. Men men men always had
long hair. was viewed as being you
know a a symbol of masculinity and
strength etc. And so when he came to
Medina and he saw that the Jews of
Medina also kept their hair that,
what did he start doing? Part it right
down the middle. He would part it right
down the middle and then braid it. Why?
Well, his head is covered all the time
in public. No one would know the
difference, right?
He knows the difference inside. He does
not want to be observed by Allah
even superficially appearing like
those
of disbelief, those of other religions,
right?
And sometimes this principle is
confused. People think well, you
know, it's only haram to imitate
non-Muslims
if you intend to imitate them. But if
you do something without the intention
of imitating them, then
you know it's okay. What do you guys
think about that? Do do you need an
intention for something this?
So one time
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was making salah. He was leading the
companions in salah
and
an issue arose where he needed to pray
the remainder of the prayer sitting
down. He needed to lead the sitting
down. So he sat
and the companions
We're praying behind him. So what's the
image now? What's the picture? We have
the imam, our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam sitting leading salah and we
have his followers in salah are all
what? Standing behind him. And so he
gestured to them to sit down. He has the
he needs to sit. He's the one who is
unable to stand. They can stand, but
they sit.
And so after the salah, he turned to
them and said,
[Silence]
He said, "You all almost
did
what the Romans and Persians do for
their leaders, meaning be standing while
their leaders are sitting."
If the imam prays prayed together.
Now did the companions who had spent the
better half of 5 years
closer to 10 years and even indirectly
and by proxy
20 years fighting against the Romans
and the Persians their sworn enemies.
Did they intend
to imitate the Romans and the Persians?
No, they didn't have that intention.
They had the intention of what? I'm able
to stand, so I pray standing. He's
unable to stand. So, he prays sitting.
However, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam still jin as being what?
As being imitation of the Romans and
Persians.
Do we understand the the
the ruling here
to back up an action that is
categorically wrong? If the c if the
action
the intention is the ruling will be
and so
for
[Silence]
the Muslim. Abu
Kava. Who is Abu Kava?
Abu Bakr Sudik's father. Abu Kohava. All
right. He accepted Islam on the day of
the conquest of Mecca.
he was a very old man
when the conquest of Mecca took place.
And Abu Bakr went and found his father
and brought him to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. And in some
narrations it was that he was blind by
this age. And he said this is my father.
He wants to
accept.
I
accept
to make you
and he's referred to as Abu Bakr and
sometimes they call him
and he had when he was brought to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his
hair was so white it was described as a
billowing cloud of whiteness
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said after he He had accepted
Islam. He said, "Change this white hair
for him and stay steer clear of using
black.
Change this white hair and steer clear
of using what?" Black for the dye. And
finally,
[Silence]
this pocket here underneath the bird.
You know, birds chipmunks and
squirrels and stuff, they to keep
their food stored up in their cheeks.
Probably the cutest thing you could ever
see in your life. But, , chickens,
lots of types of birds, they don't have
cheeks, they have beaks, right? So, they
keep the extra food that they can't
digest now in this pocket here. This
sack that is right behind their jaw,
right? Or their beak and it it blows up
when they fill it up, right?
So this is referred to in plural as
so the prophet sallall.aii Wasam tells
us in
that there will be a people that will
dye their hair at the end of time
with black and they will appear
like
the sacks of a bird.
and he specifically mentions that Ham
Ham is pigeons. So
they will dye their hair. They will dye
their beards and specifically they will
shave off all of the sides of the beard
and leave the goatee, what we call the
goatee, and then they will dye it black.
this description he tells us he says
those individuals will not smell the
scent of paradise now will they not
smell the scent of paradise because they
dyed their hair black is that what's to
be understood from the narration
what is to be understood
right so he's speaking of a type of
people. This is their hallmark. This is
their signature. So, differentiate
yourselves from them. These are the
people of hell. Not necessarily because
they dyed their hair black. That's not
what warranted them hellfire, but this
is their hallmark. This is their
signature. This is their iconic look.
So, differentiate yourselves from them.
Notice how he didn't say, "Don't use
black." This is not kindergarten. He
didn't have to spell it out. A Muslim
naturally understands.
Those are the people Allah hates. I do
not want to even appear them. This
is a known principle that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam had taught the
companions. We will end with this
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Muhammad. We also have our brother back.
He's been gone. I don't know. Have you
guys noticed that he's been gone? He
told me before he left, he's going to
India. actually was having u some very